well the last question today regarding
Prophet Muhammad Sall Ali wasallam
statement which you mentioned in your
last answer regarding the fact the uh
the gates of uh Paradise are open and
the gates of hell are closed does this
mean that we will be going to Paradise
if we die in this blessed month this
again is the same question of the same
Hadith same Hadith which occurred
earlier of musnad Ahmed Vol number two
page number 230 Hadith number 7148 and
it also appears in chapter number fiveth
number 21106 again the same Hadith the
prophet said he told the people that the
Blessed month of Ramadan is approaching
and Allah is ordering for you that you
fast in this
month and in this month the Gates of
Heaven will be open and the Gates of
Hell will be closed and the Devils will
be chained in this month is the night
ofar which is more blessed than a
thousand
months and a person who's deprived of
the pleasures of the blessings in this
month is truly a deprived person here
again this is a common question that if
the Gates of Heaven are open and the
gates of hell are closed then anyone who
dies but naturally go to Jenna because
the gates of H closed and Jenna open
does it mean that even if a non-muslim
dies in this month even he'll have to go
to Jenna the reply to this question is
when Allah say says that in this month
of Ramadan the Gates of Heaven are open
it means the Gates of Heaven are
inviting you to enter
Jenna that means that even if you do a
small deed Allah subhana waala will
multiply your reward and as the prophet
said that every deed will get a reward
times and in this month it's very easy
to enter Jenna when a prophet said
the Gates of Hell will be closed
indicating that to enter hell is
difficult in this month why because your
TAA level
rises and the chance of you to commit
sin is less and furthermore if you fast
the full month in the month of Ramadan
seeking Allah's reward all your past
will be forgiven so the moment a person
fast in this complete month of Ramadan
seeking Allah's reward all this past
sins are completely forgiven so if the
past sins are forgiven the chances of
him going to hell is
nil but what we have to realize the
criteria for the Gates of Heaven to be
open and the Gates of Hell to be closed
is that you have to
fast and
furthermore to enter Jenna you require a
ticket the ticket to go to jna is
mentioned in the Quran in Surah Al
chapter number 103 verse number 1 to 3
where Allah
says that by the token of time man is
rily in a state of loss except those who
have faith those who righteous deeds
those who exalt people to truth and
those who exalt people to patient and
perseverance this Surah according to
Imam Shafi he said that only if this
Surah was to be revealed of the Quran it
would have been sufficient for the
Salvation of mankind so important is it
is called as ra the way for salvation
and the criteria for any human being to
enter Jenna is four first is Iman second
is righteous Deeds third is exhorting
people to truth and fourth is exalting
people to patience and perseverance so
here we realize that the Gates of Heaven
are open but just because the gates are
open you can't enter you require the
ticket the ticket is Iman the ticket is
righteous deed exhorting people to truth
exhorting people to Patient perseverance
and to get this ticket is very easy in
month of
Ramadan because Iman level rises in the
month of Ramadan furthermore your
righteous deed the reward is
Multiplied it's easier you can call
people to truth your patient level
increases so this Hadith means that you
have to have the criteria then inshallah
you should go to Jenna and you'll not go
to hell but that doesn't mean that 100%
people who die will go to to Jenna
surely those who are non-believers they
have got no Iman so there's no question
that they will enter
Jenna if a person has to enter Jenna he
requires a ticket and the ticket to
Jenna is Sur Al furthermore if you read
the Hadith it says that only if you fast
in the month of
Ramadan that means and you follow all
the rules and regulations and abstain
from things which are prohibited then
the doors of heaven will be open and the
Gates of Hell will be closed furthermore
it says in this month is a night which
is equivalent to more than thousand
months indicating that even if you pray
and worship to Allah subhana wa tala in
this one night it will equivalent to
more than a thousand months is about
more than 80 years imagine so the
chances for you to get reward only in
this one night is more than a lifetime
an average human being is for 60 years
so
one is more than a thousand months is
about more than 80 years more than
average life of a human being the
chances are very easy to go to J and the
ending part of the Hadith says a person
who's
deprived of these blessings is truly a
deprived person indicating that everyone
will not go to Jenna everyone will not
find the doors of Heaven open it says
the ending part very important that a
person who's deprived of the blessings
in this month is truly a deprived person
that means telling us Muslims that if
you cannot get the benefits of the month
of Ramadan and then if you cannot go to
Jenna then you are truly a deprived
person that even includes the
non-muslims who haven't got the they're
truly the deprived
people so Dr Zak well